mind everybody out there listening far and wide that if you do not support your source
of information then you are the product and your brain space is being sold to whoever
does support the source of your news and information.
So please support whatever local independent news sources that you consume and maybe even
some of those outside of where you consume just because you know you got to keep a broader
point of view points alive out there because sooner or later you'll be caught in a little
cul-de-sac and you'll have nowhere to go and you'll rue the day you didn't support redwood
community radio.
So without further ado, let's get into Ask Your Herb Doctor.
Thank you.
Well thank you, good evening and welcome to January the 21st, 2022's edition of Ask Your
Herb Doctor.
My name is Andrew Murray.
My name is Sarah Johannesen Murray.
Welcome to our show.
Well you're listening to KMUD Garberville 91.1 FM here from the Redwood Coast of California
broadcasting nationwide and internationally to a wide range of open-minded perceptive
individuals who want to know what's really going on.
Well if you want to know what's really going on keep tuned to the show.
Don't forget to listen to the audio archives that are recorded but unfortunately I only
kept for a month or two at the most but our website has at least ten years of archives
but I've got at least another two years to put up so excuse me for that it's been a bit
busy.
Yeah I'd like to comment on the archive situation because I thought that they used to be held
for a lot longer and one of my past hosts called me up saying hey our organization sent
to people so I was able to tell Simon about that and he was able to give them a special
link.
They're up there three months as it is right now.
Interesting.
It used to be longer but there is a way that you can find a quick link to yours and you
could put that on your website too and also we as programmers should talk to Kama to try
to get it back the way it was.
We record all of them so they are intended to be put on the website but it's the same
thing I just get so busy that it just kind of slips.
So anyway you're listening to Ask Your Herb Doctor KMUD Garverville 91.1 FM from 7.30 until
the end of the show at 8 o'clock.
You're invited to call in the questions related or unrelated to this month's subject of MSG
and cancer and a continuation of estrogen and its progressively destructive effects
and induction of autoimmunity and cancer.
We have a bit of a wrap up from last month to finish and then get started with the MSG
and the glutamate etc and the links to cancer and excitotoxicity.
There's also a link to COVID and MSG through its negative effects on the immune system.
So let me see here.
The number is 707 93 3911.
So from 7.30 until the end of the show please go ahead and call up with any questions you
have related to this month's subject or if you have other questions you want to post
to Dr. Peat we'd love to hear them too.
Okay so Dr. Peat are you with us?
Yes.
Okay thanks so much for joining us again.
As usual I think let's just make sure that you are fully introduced to the audience perhaps
those people some of which may never have heard you and just let them know a little
bit about you and what your right expertise is.
Oh now you want to hear from her?
Yes please.
Okay.
I had been a student of the humanities and teaching painting and English literature and
various humanities subjects and I got interested in language and how the brain can do such
a thing as use language and I decided that the only way to make progress was to go to
a graduate school in biology and study the brain and so in 1968 I went back to the University
of Oregon and I quickly found that the nerve biology section of the department was very
dogmatic and cared more about their theories than the actual experimental evidence and
in fact didn't like to look too much at experimental results if they didn't absolutely fall in line
with the theory and I found looking around for several weeks I checked into many different
labs at the University and found that the aging research in reproductive physiology
and how it's affected by aging they were the most concerned with finding out what's really
happening.
I'm sorry I decided to do my dissertation on that which I finished in 1972 the age related
oxidative changes in the hamster uterus and surprisingly that had a huge amount of information
relative to brain function and everything else to thoroughly understand what's going
on in aging changes and how the organism redesigns cells so that they can start a new life from
a single fertilized ovum that involves the same principles that you need to look at to
see what the brain is doing in relation to behavior and understanding language and so
on.
So one thing led into another and I've been working on those subjects ever since.
Excellent.
Well from a social perspective I really appreciate your interweaving your artistic nature with
a fluid understanding perhaps which is not current I think mainstream understanding tends
to be fairly dogmatic but you have a very fluid plastic way of looking at things and
I know it's bought a very wide spotlight on a lot of subjects that we've covered and really
appreciate you sharing your wisdom with us and I know as I said many many times the archives
that we've recorded with you probably for the last 14 years nearly now there are going
to be a living testimony to what's already been confirmed I think somewhat reluctantly
by some industries because they'd like to keep control of their dominance but a lot
of these things that you've been saying have been confirmed and I think slowly but surely
people are getting a much better understanding of the way things really are unlike what they've
been told.
So I think without further ado I just wanted to say for those that are listening that there
was several several questions that I wanted to ask Dr. Peat last month about estrogen
its relationship to autoimmunity and cancer but very quickly I just wanted to cover a
couple of things from an herbal perspective surrounding estrogen and aromatase I just
want to share with people so last month I mentioned a cucurbitaceous vine bearing plant
called Momodica charantia which is a bit of melon has been used to block estrogen essentially
has estrogen modulating properties and this is an anti-diabetic plant essentially kind
of works with regulating blood glucose.
I wanted to also mention artemisinin a component really of wormwood but also artemisia annua  that
actually contains not just anti-parasitic anti-microbial and antiviral effects but has also been shown
to reduce the estrogen receptor function in breast cancer cell lines so that's worth people
taking a look at PubMed or any other peer-reviewed work done by postdocs or PhDs who are looking
at this as an interesting part of their thesis so artemisinin does have anti-estrogenic activity.
I wanted to say quickly that also tamoxifen you know may be useful in the treatment of
immune mediated disorders particularly those arising from aberrant helper T1 cell activity
including allograft rejection it's also been used with some success in Crohn's but wanted
just to bring that out that the induced shift away from cellular immunity represents a significant
step in fostering a cancerogenic environment and this may limit the anti-cancer effects
of tamoxifen and thus explained why tamoxifen is inferior compared to other anti-estrogens
many of which Dr. Peat's brought out many of which we're probably going to be covering
again quickly for preventing disease recurrence in early breast tumors early stage breast
tumors so I think let's get into before we retrace too much that was a small part of
what I wanted just to make sure they got out there first of all but I think let's just
kick off tonight with the topic of MSG and we've had the last couple of shows on estrogen
but last month specifically from an excitotoxic perspective that is where the cell is getting
so excited that essentially it goes into an early death cycle but more than certainly
in glutamate the food and drug administration has considered it safe to add to food and
it's one of the most abundantly found amino acids in nature and is present in a heterogeneous
group of foods as a flavor enhancement issued as a food additive known as E621 in the form
of hydrolyzed protein or as a purified monosodium salt and very early on and this is how I want
to ask you Dr. Peat to kind of compare these two early on they were demonstrating or they
seemingly were demonstrating the benefits of monosodium glutamate as responsible for
increasing temperature decreasing body mass and decreasing production of fat tissue so
that it would be readily taken up I mean not just because of the umami flavor and the taste
benefits a taste enhancing benefits that were conferred to foods that had monosodium glutamate
added to them and I was surprised to find that there was a wide variety of foods including
things like walnuts, garlic, onion, potatoes these will be pre-packaged perhaps dried products
not just not the fresh product although some of these products do contain their own natural
glutamate of course but and then chicken, beef, eggs, human milk and cow milk and actually
in fairly large amounts so the negative effect of this glutamine essentially was that it
suppressed the oxidation of glucose so I'm wondering there are claims of obesity whereas
before they were talking about how it was going to increase your metabolism and burn
fat and speed you up and everything else but Dr. Peat you've been looking at monosodium
glutamate and its excitotoxic effects and that will a little later on we'll get into
some of the potential cancer risks associated and why the FDA is still not banning it.
Yeah I think the weight loss thing was just a sales point to sell the flavoring substance
in the 1970s mostly J.W. Olney found that when rats were fed just a little more than
the amount that a person could normally eat in various artificial foods or add as flavoring
that the brain was damaged in a certain way that led to life long obesity, destruction
of enough of the brain that appetite remained out of control and the metabolic rate wasn't
sufficient to keep weight steady and over a period of several years he did many experiments
including showing that the same sort of molecule aspartic acid or aspartame or variations but
as long as it was acting through the glutamate receptor or the aspartate receptor it had
this range of excitatory effects that one of the positive things was that it made you
seem more alert but that alertness came at the expense of not having enough energy produced
to meet the high energy consumption caused by the excitatory action of the aspartate
or glutamate.
Is the aspartate or aspartame also like that fake sugar or spalinda or something like that?
NutraSweet I thought it was or NutraSweet, it's aspartic acid with methanol and then
it degrades into methanol and leaves methanol in your neurons.
Aspartame is super sweet, sweeter than saccharin but the amount that is toxic is very small
and they've demonstrated that it can cause brain cancer and only among others in the
late 70s was showing that the sudden appearance of a rising incidence of gliomas, malignant glial cells
tumors, brain cancer, he demonstrated you could cause those by overfeeding the glutamate
or MSG to animals and that the rise in the population, incidence and mortality from these
tumors followed by a few years the introduction of foods that were loaded with everything
from aspartame to MSG and looking at the animal research where you have no growing incidence
of brain cancer is partly caused by the artificial sweeteners and flavoring materials.
Just goes to show we can't trust the ethics of the FDA if they're allowing that type of
product on the market.
And cell phones have corresponded, for example, if a person habitually holds their cell phone
to the right ear, the incidence of brain tumors on the right side of a particular kind has
increased sharply since the use of cell phones and it happens that they are both causes of
excitotoxicity. The electromagnetic field excites the cells and you need to provide
energy to keep up with that or the cell dies and ongoing experiments show that when cells
are endangered by such things as MSG or aspartame, if you intervene by giving them a super amount
of sugar glucose or other sugar will save the neurons simply by feeding whatever is
needed to keep up with the high level of excitation. And that is an image, the excitotoxic conflict
between unavoidable stimulation of excitation combined with something interfering with the
oxidation of glucose. That isn't applicable only to aging and gliomas, a terminal type
of brain cancer usually. It applies to epilepsy, for example, if the cells aren't able to keep
up their energy production and use with the excitation as the seizure gets out of control
and damages the tissue. And it turns out that other, it isn't just nerve cells, they're
just the most obvious among the earliest to respond to extreme disparity between the energy
supply and the energy needed to meet the stimulation. But any cell that can be exaggeratedly stimulated
can be rescued if you keep the sugar supply up. But if it isn't kept up, then that cell
it becomes, for example, it can become cancerous. Excited cells can form brain tumors or they
can just die leading to dementia or various types of brain function loss depending on
which cells they are. This is like a kind of wasteful entropy then that happens as a lack
of input of the energy needed to keep the cell going. Yeah. And it's made worse by overlapping
influences. It isn't just cell phone radiation and a spark name and MSG, but it's many different
things all have that same function. So eating Chinese food has MSG in it, drinking a diet
soda, the last talking on your cell phone, holding it up to your head. And if you look
at what any stress does, no matter what you're doing to yourself, vibration or laser overstimulation
or telephone overstimulation or even simply glucose deprivation or oxygen deprivation,
they all turn out to be excitatory. I think to coin that term wasteful was probably a
good way for people who are listening to the show to understand the term excitatory. It's
kind of very wasteful blowing off of your energy with just inefficient processes.
Yeah, and it happens that the feeding of energy in the form of sugar has a sedative action
that leads to turning down the degree of excitation, the harmful influence that the damage to the
cell which might be oxygen or glucose deprivation or temperature too cold or too hot, anything
harmful turns out to activate a whole range of short-term solutions that if the cell perceives
that it is not getting enough energy to meet the needs. One alternative is to try to go
into hibernation to turn off its own needs for energy. And to do that, it has the equipment
for producing serotonin which will help to retain, prevent loss of heat through the skin,
but it also turns down the production of heat and so it leads to a colder and colder state,
suspended animation to a degree.
Another universal basic type of reaction is the formation of histamine. When a cell is
in desperate dying conditions, it forms and secretes histamine into its environment because
the histamine will open up any closed blood vessels and get more blood delivered. Estrogen
is another of these short-term emergency things. The estrogen in turn can activate the serotonin
system and cool off the whole energy consuming apparatus and it can activate the histamine
system. And there are other systems like it activates nitric oxide formation that opens
up the blood vessels the same way histamine does and it can activate heme oxygenase which
breaks down heme which had been used to make the cells energy now when it is in the desperate
condition. Breaking down the heme will provide some antioxidant function. Billy Rubin and
carbon monoxide are produced under these circumstances. The carbon monoxide can serve as an antioxidant
blocking the ability to consume oxygen until moving the system into a tort-proof or hibernation.
So it is all lots of inflammation. Lots of wasteful mechanisms to waste and deplete the
organism of energy and further send the cell into a desperate state. Michael, you had a
question. Yeah, my understanding is that the glutamate or the accent flavor is stimulating
the unami flavor and a lot of the high protein and other nutritious foods stimulate that
too. How is it that the body is able to be benefited by eating like a nice high protein
diet? Okay, yes. The hydrolyzed protein and the soy protein and a lot of those products
are totally big sources of MSG. Dr. Peat, how about the flavoring side of MSG? Or as
much its natural presence in the diet versus? Yes, that in the natural state where protein
is a rare delicacy for most animals, the urge to eat some protein, it's a definite survival
urge. You want to build muscle, make new tissue and so on. But the trouble is when the society
provides lots and lots of cheap protein, people get in the habit of not being guided by their
appetite and cravings but just eating it because it's there and even because it's considered
the most valuable food that people tend to overeat on protein after they're around the
age of 20 or so, as their growth slows down, they tend to keep eating for the 15-year-olds
they were. As long as you're growing and consuming, you respond to the signal action of the glutamate
and so on. But as soon as you've responded, you go into an anabolic state and pick up
all of those individual amino acids and make muscle and brain tissue and renew all of your
tissues and make them bigger and stronger. But once your size is established, then if
you keep eating that same amount, you're going to have a lot of excess beyond your needs,
excess histidine, tryptophan, methionine, cystine, aspartate, glutamate, all of these
potentially excitotoxic amino acids.
So when you recommend people consume 75 to 100 grams of protein a day, you're not recommending
they consume that all in the form of muscle meat or eggs. You typically don't recommend
more than two eggs a day and most of your protein requirements you believe should be
coming from dairy.
Yes, and after you're grown up in size, you should try to learn to go by your actual biological
urges rather than what advertising tells you to eat.
So how many ounces of a muscle protein, whether it's fish, shellfish, meat, chicken, would
you recommend is a safe level for adults, grown adults?
Yes, as your metabolic rate slows down and that happens steadily from puberty, it first
slows down very quickly after puberty and then it has a level decline, a steady annual
decline of ability to make new tissue and produce energy.
And so the older you are, the more careful you have to be about having an excess of the,
especially the excitotoxic amino acids.
So I guess it's just based upon your activity level and your age is what you're saying?
Yes, I think it was Adele Davis said in pointing out that gelatin is considered an incomplete
protein because animals and people can't grow if they aren't getting amino acids lacking
in gelatin, but she said she had seen lots of old women going for years, living on a
diet of toast and jello and tea, which are practically their only protein being the gelatin,
which is not a complete protein, but that was just an illustration of what a very tiny amount
of a very old person needs.
Okay, you're listening to Ask Your Herbs Doctor KMUD.
Garberville 91.1 FM from now, 7.30, till the end of the show, the 8 o'clock, you're invited
to call into questions, the number is 707 923 3911, guest speaker Dr. Raymond Peat, we're
discussing excitotoxicity and monosodium glutamate in particular, we'll carry on getting into
some of the other adverse effects of monobutamate in a moment here.
I pulled up an article that was describing the exposure of rats to monosodium glutamate
at the neonatal stage severely damaging their hypothalamic nuclei, which resulted in increased
body weight, as we've mentioned, fat deposition, decreased motor activity, secretion of growth
hormone and MSG appears to be a suitable candidate for inducing obesity, which leads to diabetes,
so this is what we're talking about, what you're talking about, what you've explained
from an excitotoxic energy wasteful activity mediated by MSG.
Funny enough, as I said at the very beginning, the FDA is still behind it, they haven't thrown
it out, they are still advocating its use or inclusion into foods, and like I said,
I was very surprised that even things like human milk and cow milk had some of the monosodium
glutamate component in it, it wasn't just the kind of thing we would typically think
about which would be Chinese food, for example, or soy, etc.
I wonder if it's allowed to be in products without being listed as an additive, Dr. Peat,
do you know anything about that?
I think legally it has to be listed, they have some alternatives like calling it a vegetable
broth or something, when it's really an MSG extracted from soybean.
Can it be natural flavor if it's less than a certain percentage, like some other stuff?
I suppose so.
What about tamari?
Sorry, before we move on from the MSG topic, tamari is a wheat-free soy sauce and fermented
soy protein, so doesn't that form like a natural MSG as well?
Yeah.
So is that something that should be limited in someone's diet?
I think so.
Okay, so I wanted just to bring out quickly that I saw an article again while I was looking
at this month's subject this afternoon, a curcumin from Turmeric protects against monosodium
glutamate neurotoxicity and decreasing NMDA2B, which is N-methyl-D-aspartate receptor 2B,
and I know, Dr. Peat, you'd mentioned NMDA earlier, and that's kind of an interesting
article saying that it basically affected this expression in the rat hippocampus.
So that's another good plus point for Turmeric and its anti-inflammatory activity, also directly.
There are lots of the flavonoids like quercetin and murisetin in coffee, and coffee has lots
of tissue-protective anti-cancer, anti-dementia effects that I think are largely the effect
of the flavonoid components.
I wonder this probably through a free radical quenching process.
Okay, another article I pulled out mentioned that the vital role of the hippocampus in
memory formation and regulation of behavior showing that glutamate was involved in increasing
the levels of pro-inflammatory cytokines, an example of tumor necrosis factor alpha
being one of them, which contributes to the brain damage and the death of neurons.
So this gave a mechanism by which that would happen.
Yeah, and there has been a lot of study of how the excitotoxic things like glutamate,
what they're actually doing to make the cell become more active, and they assumed for many
of the studies that glucose was somehow able to reduce the uptake or retention by the cell
of the excitotoxic agent, but a more detailed study found that, in fact, the cells were
being protected by high glucose addition without changing the concentration of aspartate or
glutamate inside the cell.
But what was happening was that normally the process of responding to the excitotoxin means
that the cell is taking up and retaining excitatory molecule calcium, which should be an extracellular
molecule when the cell retains too much and goes into the excited, inflamed energy wasting
state, and what they found was that the addition of extra glucose allowed the cell to extrude
more calcium.
As it continued to metabolize, the calcium was being pushed out of the cell under the
influence of the glucose, and apparently the mechanism for that is that glucose promotes
the increase of carbon dioxide formation as it's metabolized, and the carbon dioxide forming
the carbonic acid leaves the cell and takes with it the counter-ion, the doubly positively
charged calcium and some sodium, so the flow of carbonic acid out of the cell is taking
care of the calcium accumulation product which is the basic cause of the inflammation, pain,
and cell death.
Okay, if you're listening to Ask Your Herb Doctor Garverille, 91.1 FM.
From now until 8 o'clock, you've invited to call in at 707-923-3911.
So let me just quickly outline the typical foods that people will probably be aware or
unaware of that are glutamate rich, and it's not a bash at the vegetarians, but it just
so happens that hydrolyzed vegetable protein is very high in glutamate, autolyzed yeast,
hydrolyzed yeast, yeast extracts, soy extracts, and protein isolate are all very high in glutamate.
These do form, without being prejudiced in any way, do form a fairly large part of a
vegetarian or a vegan diet as an alternative protein source, but they do contain a lot
of glutamate, so just to be aware of that.
Yeah, a lot of bullions, I notice, even if they're organic and they say organic vegetable
bullion or organic chicken bullion or beef bullion, they have a yeast extract, and I
notice if I use that or eat that, I feel like I've had an MSG burn on my tongue.
Okay, we have a caller, so let's take this next caller.
Caller, you're on the air.
Where are you from?
What's your question?
I live on the Avenue of the Giants, where I pick up trash, and my question is going
to take you guys back to the basics.
Can you explain the inflammation, what you mean, is the inflammation of the cells or
is the inflammation around the muscle tissue and particularly around like arthritis and
just the aches and pains of getting older?
Okay, Dr. Peat, would you want to briefly explain inflammation in terms of its physical process?
People in recent years have been talking about inflammation, the inflammation, as if that
explains something, but the process of aging obviously involves increased inflammation
in every sense we know, but the problem is to see what the basic events are in cell structure
and pain, excitation, inflammation and aging all have these aspects of excitotoxic cell
damage and the inability to remedy the problem by making enough energy or delivering enough
energy.
The heme oxygenase, one of the emergency enzymes that produces carbon monoxide, there have
been probably 95% of the publications are describing carbon monoxide as an antioxidant,
it's very protective and so on, but if you look at the deteriorated brain in old age,
there is more carbon monoxide in it than at any previous life stage, so carbon monoxide
presence is a degenerative aspect of inflammation and cell deterioration.
If you block the formation of nitric oxide, for example, a traumatic wound to the head
or spinal cord, if you block the formation of carbon monoxide, you prevent most of the
damage development of edema and cell death and so on, so the chemistry of aging, inflammation
and deterioration, it's a complex of things that express the same idea as excitotoxicity.
And wasteful energy waste processes.
Okay, great.
Well, listen, we've got two more callers on the line, so thank you for your last call.
An administrative note to that first caller, Kevin, we lost your phone number, please call
us back.
He wants to volunteer for us and we're stoked that he wants to volunteer for us, but we lost
his phone number.
So, Kevin, please call back and here's our next caller.
Call away from and what's your question?
I think you have a radio.
Oh no, the caller didn't listen on their phone like I asked, oh well, here's our next caller.
Okay, please.
Next caller, this is you.
Yeah, that second caller should call back when they get a moment, so next caller, where
you from?
What's your question?
Oh yeah, I'm from South Central Los Angeles.
I was listening to the conversation and what I wanted to know was how long does the body
take, you know, to heal from all the damage, let's say you reduce all the estrogen, the
pollen, saturated fat, all the inflammatory things, how long does it take for somebody's
body to reverse the damage, is there a difference in age or is it the same for everyone?
Yeah, the young person with a higher metabolic rate can change everything more quickly.
The average person, if you move from a country that eats a lot of polyunsaturated fats to
a country that eats very little of them, it can take four years to equilibrate to the
new balance in the diet.
But if you make an extreme effort, like one of the early researchers in suppose the sensuality
of polyunsaturated fats, they were going to demonstrate that he would get sick if he ate
a laboratory purified diet, absolutely lacking polyunsaturated fats, but about three or four
months into the diet all of his chronic health problems disappeared, or chronic migraines
and other symptoms and stayed away for as long as was reported.
So in his case with an extreme avoidance of just one harmful nutrient, his lifelong problems
disappeared in just a few months.
Wow, so that would be also to, like if you reduce things to get rid of estrogen as well,
for they say my wife has suffered from fibroids and has had a couple miscarriages such as
fibroids.
Yeah, with the right amount, for example, a friend of mine who was 40 and wanted to
get pregnant, the picture showed that she had a tennis ball-sized fibroid blocking the
end of her uterus so the tubes couldn't open to deliver the ovum.
But she took an overdose of fibroid and every month the doctor, besides telling her she
was going to die from taking too much thyroid, made an image showing that the fibroid was
shrunken, and every month it got smaller and I think it was about the fifth month it had
become about a fourth of its original size and she was pregnant.
So the five months made a big difference just by using thyroid hormone, natural thyroid
hormone, that lowered her estrogen and improved her liver function.
And there were so many other out of balance components of the diet, too much iron in most
people's food, too much methionine, aspartate, glutamate, cysteine.
By fixing any one component you can see drastic effects, so if you've fixed half a dozen of
these things that are out of balance, it should produce just very huge effects quickly.
Okay, we do have another caller on here, so let's...
Thank you very much, you guys.
Yeah, you're very welcome.
Thanks for calling in.
Thank you for your call.
We do have another caller, so let's make sure we get time for this next person.
If you're listening and you'd like to call in, we've still another at least five or eight
minutes, number 707-923-3911, our guest speaker, Dr. Raymond Peake.
So caller, you're on the airway from?
What's your question?
Hi, I'm from Arcata.
My question is, I have a young grandson who has had two episodes of big intestinal bleeding,
a couple of visits to a pediatric hospital with every scope of his upper and lower GI
done not finding anything, figuring it's something called Mecol, some lesion in your small intestine.
My question is, could you recommend any foods that would be soothing to the GI tract or
nutritionally beneficial especially?
The people vary in their sensitivities, but the first thing to do would be to absolutely
avoid foods that have added gums, especially carrageenan, but a very high percentage of
foods now contain vegetable gums or microbial gums or carrageenan, all of which are very
pro-inflammatory, and just knocking out those foods can stop things like chronic bowel bleeding.
Okay, I appreciate that.
Would aloe vera or flipriome be some kind of panacea to help be soothing, or have you
any recommendations?
I would ultimately figure out what exactly it is, a lesion or diverticulum or whatever.
How old is your grandson?
Nine.
That's young.
Just straight off the top, it might sound a little mild, but in Germany and in Europe,
obviously in England, where I grew up and I studied herbal medicine, chamomile was the
number one GI anti-inflammatory.
It's got a fairly pronounced effect in blocking inflammation and soothing the GI tract, so
chamomile is mother of the gut, nurse of the gut, and that would be one of the first things
that I would give somebody from a herbal perspective, obviously, depending on what kind of bleeding
we're talking about, gentle tannins would also be indicated from an herbal perspective
to gently astringent the capillaries or the other tissues that are leaking blood into
the lumen of the small intestine or large intestine.
That can be as simple as black tea or green tea.
Black tea would be totally indicated, as would many other astringent containing herbs like
potentilla and...and it's very important to check his thyroid and vitamin D levels, because
a deficiency of either of those can make the intestine hypersensitive to inflammation.
It would look like, if you haven't already done, it's, and I imagine it's been looked
at, but obviously hemoglobin would be looked at, because I would imagine if he's had long-term
chronic bleeding, it'd be anemic, and that's going to be a negative factor for him in terms
of his energy and to support that, plenty of foods that would contain naturally present
iron rather than any iron supplement, as Dr. Peat already mentioned, iron is very reactive
and is quite an inflammatory and damaging molecule, so definitely go with foods that
would be iron-rich and liver.
Oh, and avoiding synthetic vitamin C, as you mentioned, iron, the synthetic vitamin C reacts
with the traces of iron in your body to produce inflammation.
Okay, we have one more caller.
Caller, the last person who was on, the lady with the grandson, if you ever wanted to get
any more information from us, you can always email me, andrew@westernbotanicalmedicine.com,
give you an outline of what would be a fairly good diet, and if you want to take it any
further, we can always discuss it, but let's take this next caller.
Caller, you're on the way from, what's your question?
Hi, I'm a person from Queens, New York.
I have a question about dentistry.
I would like to know, what would you say, Dr. Peat, are the basic consequences of not
killing a cavity, and is there any damage to the nervous system that takes place if
you leave the cavity unfilled?
A cavity?
Yeah, talking about dentistry and a cavity that he's potentially having dealt with but
maybe considered not.
If the damage is only into the enamel, that can be remineralized, but once it's, if it
enters into the dentine, then it really needs to be filled.
I think it's my understanding that cavities killed more people than anything else in the
middle ages, just because it would rot depending on how I left the carrier as well, yeah.
Yeah, dental disease is definitely a big killer.
Okay, well, let me just say this.
I think probably I'd like to ask you a few more questions, Dr. Peat.
I'm not too sure if anyone else is calling in with any questions, but I did want to just
get out this information for people to take a look at.
You mentioned a researcher, Blaylock.
Now I looked up this person and in the International Journal of Vaccine Theory Practice and Research
dated January 2021, I saw a very interesting article.
It wasn't actually related straight away to excitotoxicity, but the title was excitotoxicity
and immuno-excitotoxicity as a critical component of the cytokine storm reaction in pulmonary
viral infection, including SARS-CoV-2.
Basically stating that this hyperimmune state secondary to dysregulation of the immune system
during lower pulmonary viral infections was ultimately causative in the end for cytokine
storm and that a researcher called Morimoto et al., the people that formed this particular
thesis found that co-injection of lipopolysaccharide, which we've always mentioned as being a very
negative substance in the body, plus the NMDA agonist, which is a compound called ibotenate
or ibotenic acid from aminita muscaria of all things.
I just wanted to bring this out because on a side note, aminita muscaria having been used
as a hallucinogen, certainly very liver-toxic, but obviously has more significant neuronal
damage causative activity through the exocytoxic arm of the reaction.
The SARS-CoV-2 cytokine storm thing is quite interesting from that immuno-excitotoxicity.
Okay, I do want to say one more thing about the caller who called from New York asking
about cavities.
We see a holistic dentist in Medford, Oregon, and he recommends Lugol's iodine for those
cavities that are just invading the enamel, the tooth, rather than going all the way into
the dentine.
He said because it's so close on the periodic table of elements to fluoride, and it is not
neurotoxic like fluoride is, it's a safe alternative to use, besides being antimicrobial, a low
percentage solution of iodine called Lugol's iodine is very helpful for remineralizing superficial
cavities.
I'll throw a plug out there for flossing, as one wise person said, "Floss only those
teeth you wish to keep."
Okay, thanks so much for your time, Dr. Peat.
I just wanted to read out one last thing before we close the show.
Okay, so last month I came out with the same paragraph.
I've changed it slightly, but again, Europe has lifted the mandate for everything related
to COVID as well as iodine.
Britain, England, not Europe.
The subject of the paragraph I just want to read out now slowly so people can hear and
understand.
"Authoritarianism and the age of acceptance have it all and have nothing.
We're evolving as a species, and with our evolution comes a concept of deranged acceptance.
Nature is not accepting, but rather through evolutionary pressure, it selects the fittest
and is quite barbaric.
It takes no prisoners and is quite merciless.
Rules exist and nature obeys them. They are set from the foundation of the world, which
we recently have also learned to meddle with and derange, like viruses and gain-of-function
research and the origins of COVID.
The opposite, perhaps, of the all-encompassing embrace of everything is allowable are the
immutable laws set in place which we are constrained to, like time, gravity and death.
Authoritarianism, like cultural Marxism, is at odds with our founding fathers' constitution
of life, liberty and the pursuit of happiness, which is a God-ordained decree, immutable
and self-evident echoing Martin Luther's famous speech from the Emancipation Proclamation.
Like gain-of-function research and authoritarianism, these are set at odds with their counterpart
and are to be resisted with your life.
Life demands that fitness be preserved and aims at physical and spiritual health.
I put it to you that with increasing authoritarianism and draconian legislation aimed at making us
happier to coexist with everything except everything, have no boundaries and have no morals, I leave
you with this, have at it or resist and live.
Until the third Friday of next month, my name's Andrew Murray.
My name's Sarah Murray. Thank you for listening.
Thank you.
[MUSIC]